I ladies and gentlemen, Garfunkel
ourself doing Tom am I saying here?
That was clearly not from the special
that was from last season of another
period. If you haven't seen it, it takes
place in 1902. It's like a reality show.
70 need to know too. And that's all real
stuff. It's based on all real stuff.
That finger contraption is real from
the turn of the century. It's, yeah,
those are all afraid techniques
except for the bicycle. We're like,
we have to add something to it. Yes, we
had to. Yes. And so we have the bike.
Oh Ricky, you are really a renaissance
woman. You are a actress, a comedian,
a musician. You created another period.
You were right or another period.
The show runner. Now we have new special
uh, coming this week. It was great. Yeah.
Well thank you for making time
and coming here to Google.
I like tried to tell my parents
what I do all day. I'm just like,
I don't know everything. I don't
know. Just everything in there like,
well what do you like? It's always
different. It's always, no, no, no.
I got to go and yeah, that's basically
their understanding of my job.
And you were here today without your
cohort. You were here without oats today
in La Doing Conan today.
Oh, I know. Here we are.
You drew the short Straw, I'm
sure. Um, so Garfield's one notes.
Let's just start with what people
need to know. Why Garfunkel?
Well,
I was at a a hall and Oates concert
at the Hollywood bowl and I really bad
seats. I was, it was
like I was waitressing,
I was in the back and so basically you
can only watch it on the monitors and the
camera had a close up of Darryl that he
kind of had like a wind machine kind of
situation. It was the close of Daryl and
then it was like, oh, it's in the band.
So oats was only in the wide shot
or like the moving right past him.
And there was no two shot.
It was just Daryl and then everyone else.
And for some reason that just made me
laugh and I was like, who set that up?
Like how does it feel to be oats? And
then, yeah, we kind of went from there,
but we didn't realize about two years
ago someone sent us this like Simpsons
thing where they had almost
the same joke. You're like, ah,
they have something called like it was
like Nash Oats and Garfunkel or something,
but it was close enough where
we were like, well okay.
Oh well I mean too late now.
That's her name.
So, uh, of course, uh, Kate is
oats. You were Garfunkel? Yes.
How did you guys get together?
We were both auditioning for commercials
and neither of us were working cause it
was all kind of like maxim girls, like
that Doritos girl, if you guys remember.
It was all like that kind of look.
And then all of a sudden they just
started casting girls with big eyes.
And so she and I just got called
back for everything. I've nowhere,
like I got dropped by,
I like I just shouldn't for like a couple
of years got dropped by my commercial
agent, never booked anything.
And then out of nowhere,
like Kate and I were just in all the
commercials were like, what is happening?
It didn't last that long,
but we just kept seeing each other
at callbacks and then she came up and
introduced me, introduce yourself to
me at UCB and then went from there.
And how did the uh, have the musician,
uh, kind of blind get into it? How did it
became like these weird soulmate friends,
I don't even know how to explain it.
Like Kate's boyfriend who was with
her when we met, like on the way home,
he was like,
you like her more than you like me.
And Kate says she remembers
going like, yeah. So yeah.
And then we found out that we both
wrote comedy songs on our own,
nice to play them in college and Kate
was kind of playing these comedy songs
around town and I would play at parties,
like we'd been doing it on our own in an
unofficial capacity for like 10 years.
And so then we're just like,
oh, let's just do this together.
When was your first
Gig together? Um, Gosh,
when I think it's been like eight years
maybe. It's been a long time. Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
I think it was 2008 is we made this short
that like Kate was my imaginary friend
and it was a musical and we wrote the
songs for it and just made it. Yeah.
Very cool. And kind of since then, yeah.
Uh, what is your song process like? I know
the old creative process question, but
basically it's evolved because we've
kind of like sound out like our,
what we're good at and how to do it.
So basically we'll have a topic and
then we just brainstorm on it for ever.
And this is only the songs that make it,
like the songs that don't,
I don't even know, they just like
we just throw them in the garbage,
but basically we brainstorm forever.
Well it's like a 20 page document of
anything we've ever thought about this
topic.
And then she gives it to me and I sort
of like narrow it down and come up with a
title. And then after I had the title,
I go and do a first pass of the lyrics,
give it to Kate,
she does a first pass at the melody.
And then we get together and sort
of, you know, make it together.
But she just has these like catchy
melodies that are always in her head. So
what did you guys ever go on?
Like a specific bitch of like you want
to like hit a joke and then a song comes
around that or
sometimes we'll get a title if we,
but like if you cause this,
there's not enough to sustain a joke for
like three minutes and we don't do it.
Cause like some things
are good as one line,
but then like what do you say after that?
You know,
it's just like I've got nothing left.
So a lot of most things ended up
in the garbage because they don't,
we can't like blow them
out to a whole song.
Now this leads to the very first
special trying to be special. Yes.
And of course a spoiler alert. I have
seen it. So I'll try and keep it, uh,
keep it close. But uh, the specialist
about trying to make a special,
yes, it is. It's very meta.
It's basically Kate and I are like in a
hotel room and we had this gig that you
think went really badly and we're just
like, this sucks. That is, we're so tired.
We're on the, and I'm like, do you
think we should do something different?
She's like, I don't know. And I'm
like, well, we're, we're 36 years old.
We have no husbands,
no real jobs, no kids.
Like our lives are amazing.
And she's like, yeah, totally.
Like the only Nigga can make it better as
a comedy special. And so we're like, oh,
we don't have money to
make a comedy special.
So we do a fundraiser concert in order
to make money to be able to put it on the
special. So, and then you see, you
see the fundraiser concert. So yeah.
And this, uh, this comes out this
coming week on Cinco de Mayo, May 5th.
It's a available on Vimeo. Yeah.
So going the digital route.
Yeah. We decided to do something
different because the meal,
it's like they have the best player.
Like they just do like businesses use it,
they're the best player.
And you can just download it and have
it on your computer forever. I'm like,
that's just, I don't know. It seemed
like, and they don't give notes,
they have full your full 100%
creative control. So we were like,
that kind of feels the same
budget as everyone else.
Kind of like oh no notes and yeah,
let's do that.
So that's what we decided to go with.
Um,
one thing in the special that we were
talking about prior is just the quirkiness
of your guys' characters and it makes
everything seemed so just spur of the
moment.
Right. And some of it is, some
of it is like a lot we don't,
when we go on tour,
we don't know what we're going to talk
about when we walk out, unless we like,
unless something really weird happened
right before then we're like, okay,
we're going to talk about that.
But usually we just walk out and like
begin and sometimes it goes better than
other times.
You actually said that
you and Kay had s uh,
she stuff like UCB Improv background?
No, we were there seeing a
friend's show, what we were seeing,
a dead Benson show and yeah,
we were both friends with him.
I made friends with him on Friendster.
That's real as real.
He saw some play that I was in. It was
like, your plate is funny. And I was like,
I just saw you do comedy.
And then we were like loose
acquaintances and he's like,
well come to my next show.
That's where I met Kate.
It's actually funny. I was first exposed
to you guys from Doug Benson's podcast.
Really? He's been so nice to us since
day one. He always has us on there.
He's just like been a good friend to
us. Fair enough. Yeah. He opened first,
last time we were in la just to be nice,
like didn't want any money.
He just like opened for us.
It was, yeah, it was cool.
All right, so just shifting over since
we saw the another period clip to start.
Um, so another period has
created and written by you
and Natasha Gara and you did
say it's a,
it's like a reality show based in 1902.
Yeah. We save. It's
like, it's like a family,
like the Kardashians moved into Downton
Abbey. So this is it set in America.
It's a Newport,
Rhode Island.
These people are not class
either new money and they just,
they have unlimited money but it's brand
new and our dad has a magnate magnate.
He owns all the badness
in the world I guess.
And then we just are like pieces of
garbage that have no problems but complain
all day long.
So
on comedy central, a season two comes
out in June, June 15th, June 15th,
comedy central. How did that
come about with you and Natasha?
Was that just a conversation?
Natasha and I, we went to, um, do,
we went on like a charity trip to
Senegal for malaria, no more it,
which is actually an incredible
organization like you have to,
they're like actually curing malaria.
Like they're actually doing stuff.
It's so crazy.
But I love that company.
And we went to Senegal and it was just
like, we just bonded. It's so hot.
And we were just, we didn't know we
were doing and it was, it was intense.
And so we just became friends and
then kind of when we were flying back,
Natasha was like, I looked
at your imdv and I'm like,
yeah, like, okay. She's like,
no,
I just,
you have like 80 credits on there and how
many of those things if you've been in
that are actually funny. And I was like,
I was like, that's a good question.
I was like, I don't know too.
And she's like, I have zero,
I've like 50 things and zero
things are funny. And she's like,
I feel like that's weird.
She was like,
I think like we needed to write stuff
and make funny stuff cause why is
everything not funny? And I'm
like, all right, good point.
And so we started trying to come up with
an idea and then we were like kind of
stuck.
And then if,
so we went out and drank a bunch of wine
and then came up with the idea as you
do when you're like, fuck it, let's get
wasted. And they're like, I know the idea.
Like it's a terrible creative process,
but it totally works.
So, uh, speaking of volume to be,
actually I found myself watching
million dollar baby recently.
I was totally blind side and I was
like, oh my God, that's an intense,
I'm a renaissance woman as,
yeah, no, that was my first
movie. It was so crazy.
I just thought it was going
up from there. No, I was like,
my first movie has ever been won.
The Oscar like sky's the limit.
And then I like still didn't get an agent
for like another two or three years.
I was like, okay, so it's going to be
slower. Yeah. But it was really awesome.
It was crazy.
Do you have to make my first name?
It was the Clint Eastwood and Hilary
Swank and Margo Martindale did I ever did
and I'm like, okay, it's fine. I'm
fine. I totally deserve to be here.
I just,
you know.
Well congratulations. Thanks.
Picture. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
It really changed my life.
I'll just,
you guys know we will be taking
questions from the audience.
There are microphones in both the aisles.
If you want to just go up there,
I'll call on you and do it like school.
I feel like
my back and you clap the hardest so you
have to ask me a question and get the
ball rolling. I just, I, I
sense you're like, I just,
I like your whole energy and it made me
feel good at, as I was walking out here.
So not to put you on the spot, but you
have to think of something to ask me.
You can wait. Okay. So you think about
it and we'll get back to you. Okay.
Uh, if I was in the audience and I wasn't
lucky enough to be moderating this,
I would ask you a very important question.
What does it like dating Fozzie bear?
It's pretty sexy. It's like, yeah, he's,
he's pretty smooth. He's,
yeah, no, I actually loved,
I loved being on the methods.
I wasn't big methods fan. I know that
people are like always sat there.
Like I always loved the flash and it's
like, no you didn't. No you didn't.
You didn't love that growing up.
But I actually did love the muppets.
I would have Mrs. Miss, miss piggy, miss
piggy birthday cakes and you know, I just,
I loved it. So it was pretty
cool. I didn't know how it worked.
I didn't know there was so many people
controlling a up or there's like monitors
everywhere and you're on just like raised
platform and it's pretty, you know,
what is the process of like
doing a scene with Fozzy? It's,
there's just so many people involved.
There's so many actors like
making this thing come to life.
There's like one guy that does the left
arm and when they're all working in this,
like they just know each
other so well and they,
they have like these things on their
heads where they can see through the mud.
Like it's just a whole technical
process that they find very easy.
And the guy who played Fonzie also
does the voice of piggy and animal.
That's like his talent
basically unlimited. He does
all three of those. Yeah.
What do you got?
[inaudible] I guess first of all,
thank you so much for coming.
Um, huge fan and have been for
years. I like to feel that your song,
I don't know who you are, is my
own personal anthem. I know, right?
I'm terrible with names and
faces and it's really your fault.
Yeah. For people that don't know what this
is, we have a song about, it's called,
I don't know who you are,
which you can figure out what that is,
but as people who have come up to you
and they know who you are but you don't
know who they are and they get mad and
we have this hypothesis that it's like
their fault because they're
not interesting enough.
They would have like a thing and so
they kind of blend and then it's not our
fault.
Yeah.
Oh, so that's amazing. So thank
you so much for opening up my life.
Um, so, uh, I discovered you
guys are amazing Garfunkel
notes. There's another, uh,
comedy folk duo, I'm sure you've heard
of called flight of the Conchords. Yes.
And it seems such an odd thing to me that
there were two comedy photos that were
so hysterically funny,
had really successful songwriting
careers and then made specials where they
incorporated those songs.
You guys inspired by each
other? Do you collaborate?
Do you guys all hang out in
some really cool bar somewhere?
I've never met Brett,
but I know Jermaine and Jermaine is
actually on the upcoming season of another
period. He's doing two episodes
a season, which is so cool.
He flew in from New Zealand just to
do the show and he plays a priest.
It's like, it's like every single thing
he says is funny. So we were very,
very excited. But you mean I
actually became friends on Twitter.
Like he just sent me a DM
one day being like, hey,
there's like eight people in the
world to do what we do. What's up?
And I was like, I know, it's so crazy.
Right? And he was like, how weird is it,
what we're doing? We're in comedy
folk. Like who does that? So I'm like,
I don't know. And then we just lived in
like Twitter acquaintances since then.
And then he agreed to do the show,
which was so cool.
So no plans for some grand
mega band or something.
I mean, I would be so down
quartet. I mean I wish,
I hope I'm going to put up,
I don't know Brett,
but I would love to just putting it out
and now it's out in the world. Yeah,
it's in the universe now. It's going to
happen. Thank you. Thanks. Thank you.
[inaudible] I don't know who you are song.
It was really weird because everyone
like takes your point of view,
which is like,
I don't remember people either,
you know you put yourself in the hero
position but then one person came up to us
after a show and I'm like, that's all he
is so mean. And I was like, wait, why?
Like what? He goes, people
always forget me and I was like,
Oh God.
And he put it,
he put himself in the other like
split yourself in like the hero shoes.
Like you hear a bit about other people
being annoying. But like I am a note.
Like you don't put your,
I don't know.
I thought that was so strange and I
didn't know what to say. I was like,
I think you should not, you should like,
like change your perspective on this.
Like do you forget people? And
he's like, no, really sorry man.
I Dunno.
But speaking of that,
another one of your songs seems like it
may come across as aggressive to people.
Pregnant women are smug.
Have you ever had any of
for that? I mean, yeah, but not
any of that. Like you care about.
I don't know. What are you going? Oh, you
know, like I don't like that. I'm like,
okay. Right. Like it doesn't, it
doesn't ever hurt my feelings ever.
But like so many more
people had been like,
like Amanda Palmer is pregnant,
she sees saying pregnant women
are smug and her whole tour,
like she's like took it on.
And a lot of people,
like we got these onesies made that say
my mommy's smug and they just like sold
out people.
Just people that just buy them.
So I think probably for gag gifts for
baby showers, but I think, I dunno,
most people own it. I feel like if
you're pregnant and acting like that,
like you know it and like you can, like,
you're allowed to, there's no, yeah,
you're just allowed to do that. But
I think you know it, the woman card,
the woman card,
I know the pregnant woman card that's,
that's more powerful than the
woman card I think. Cause like,
cause no one can say that you're not going
through whatever you're saying you're
going through. Like they're like, no,
my, my ankles hurt. And you're like,
okay. Like you can't, you can't be like,
no they don't. You know, you have no idea.
I'll speak your songs. I want to, uh,
I am dating a 31 year old woman
who loves 29 31. Oh cool. So, uh,
thank you for that.
From her.
She feels like there's no one left
and that's why she's dating him.
Maybe I'm telling you,
I mean,
that's exactly what I said when she
was like, Oh man, that's so cool.
And I was just like, wait a
second. Just got really real.
We'll take that.
Like some people have taken it is here.
Like I was at a baseball game the other
day and this girl turns out, she's like,
are you the girl from the 29 31
video? And I was like, yeah, yeah.
And she didn't think we wrote it.
She thought we were like acting
in this video and she's like,
I relate to that song still match.
I'm 30 and I know my life is about to
get really bad. And I was like, no,
it's just a joke. It's not
even like, it's not real.
Like it's not necessarily that,
it's just like a joke.
It was about like basically me and
kids kind of perspective on love and we
weren't even 29 31 at the time.
We just thought those were funny numbers.
We were like 31 and 33 but we're like,
no, it's not. It's funny. Um, yeah,
but she's like,
I just know everything's going to get bad
and I got to meet someone soon and she
was so pretty and like I was,
I'm like, okay. I'm like, sorry,
maybe you shouldn't watch that video.
It's like just a joke.
Oh that's it. Out of all of the
songs, you and Kate, if put together,
what is like your go to like which of
which is your favorite baby basically?
What's your favorite thing?
My favorite
song is one that we've actually never
played on. It's just an an album,
but it is on our TV show.
It's called such a loser.
And it's this anthem for people who are
trying, cause like we like just like,
I mean you guys are all on the Internet.
You understand?
Like when you put something out there,
you just get all this criticism and,
and it kind of feels like there's like
this hierarchy where it's like winners,
like people who just don't do anything
but like comment on it and then losers.
But like we just feel like
those should be switched.
Like winners are just like they
want and you got it like they did.
But like the people who try and
the people who comment on it,
it should be like a different hierarchy
so that the commenters should just be
like whatever.
And so we wrote a song about in praise
of people who are trying and because if
you're failing, not much, you're trying
that much. So it's, it's not a funny song.
It's totally sentimental, but I think
it's the best thing we've ever written.
So yeah,
look it up.
It was like a cartoon made of it.
People play it for their kids.
Uh, with the, with your song
writing process, you seem
to then also go into video.
Uh, so what is that like? Do you ever
like get kind of bogged down and like, oh,
this would look great visually
so we should enter the
song or is that well after
that,
nope, we don't have that
kind of forethought when
he's like, oh, I don't know.
I guess we just film some stuff.
Yeah,
we don't really ever think
about that part of the song.
And like for such a loser,
we had an animated by these people in
Boston who are so incredible and they just
sent us this thing and Kate and I,
we always have a million notes
were always were so nitpicky,
it takes us forever and do anything. And
they sent it and we just started crying,
both of us and we're like,
this is perfect.
And they were like,
well we have like four rounds of
notes built in. And we're like,
so sometimes it's like that easy.
That was going to say,
so for you to know it's a really a bad,
oh no, no, no, no. I always have so many
notes, but this one, it was just like,
it was perfect and so you don't want
to, if it's perfect, it's perfect. Yeah.
You know, so, but yeah, I'm
pretty, I'm like pretty hands
on with everything. Okay.
I like to be in every moment of
everything like Natasha or editing another
period right now and we're in the
editing room from like 10 to eight every
single day. We just get her nails
done in there. I mean like, yeah,
we're hands on. Great. Um, okay.
In another period, um, uh, uh,
in another period coming up,
what can we look forward to?
You mentioned that Jermaine
was going to be on me
and Andrew Reynolds is on this new
season playing like a dashing prince type
person. We have, um,
Harriet Tubman is in our premiere and
which is so crazy that now she's on money,
well about to be on money. Um, because we
have her as a, she's a branding expert.
We have her as like this Oprah type
person. And she's basically like,
how do you think I'm the only name
associated with this entire movement?
She's like,
I did that shit.
Like on our show. People are going to have
mixed reactions to it. They really are.
And we're prepared for that.
But it is
funny if you watch it, it's
just like it's, you know,
cause you think about your like how
did one person, how did that happen?
Like there was so many people, but yes.
So you just think through history. Yeah.
And now she's going to be on money.
So I guess it worked
in that vein.
Uh,
you mentioned earlier than a lot of
things are from 1902 and then you, yes.
Yes.
I'm so much stuff is true though.
Some people think we make up this stuff
and it's like, like we have like cocaine,
wine. Like that was just a popular drink
that was not, we didn't make that up.
People had cocaine mine all the time.
It's just those kinds of things are
just real Freud masturbating people.
It's just real.
So that's a real, uh, a real clip entirely
with Freud. Yes. That was not right.
Cause Cornell, Sigmund
Freud. All right, great.
Um, thank you so much for being
here. We really appreciate it.
If anyone would like to meet
Ricky afterwards, we'll be
right here. No, right here.
Yeah. If you didn't want to
ask your questions directly,
I mean,
thank you so much for being here.
Thank you for having regular. No.